voilà pourquoi je peux pas garder le
slim à la télé ou voilà pas tellement
rêver vibrer
je me suis lavé les dents j'ai fait mes
devoirs pour coiffer pas calculé tous
les copains je regarde la télé pourrait
doubler
non non j'ai pas priver le peuple exige
une grille je vais pas crier il va
commencer le film ne s'agit pas de
routine mais tu vois je vais me venger
ils savent pas ils savent pas qui je
suis
ils savent pas que mon berceau a été
bombardée accidentellement par des
rayons gamma
ils savent pas que je suis un mutant
avec des pouvoirs ultra sensorielle ils
savent pas que je m'appelle gold au pub
non du corac no more d'aurac ap le monde
la vengeance de morag fratrie
le monstre qui se réveille
pas l'empêcher de sortir toi comme wei
qui me bouffe je suis vice que je pus
non chez les femmes la veille but il
commençait le cinéma et séries sur foire
ici tous les deux je les ai démasqué
s'ils veulent pas que je regarde le film
c'est parce que c'est pas mon père et
c'est pas ma mère tous les deux c'est
des extraterrestres qui ont pris des
enveloppes humaines pour préparer la
venue des fourmis géantes d'oméga défaut
miary
bordeaux a on a besoin de toi dire de
neutrons qui transperce ces lasers qui
les brûle la passe qui tue c'est l'acide
alors je pu encore plus est fourni et
sans bon maintenant j'attaque les
extraterrestres j'ai dépassé
je découpe mon père j'écrase ma mère je
coupe les têtes
le sang coule à flot et je sus au sens
c'était la maman dit moment je voulais
demander pourquoi je peux pas regarder
le film à la télé parce que c'est pas un
film pour moi mais pourquoi c'est un
film pour moi parce que c'est un film
d'amour